[Music]
so yeah what probably if you are coming
from Spain or Latin America everybody
knows about us every time we are we
started as a as a very elite company we
are diversifying our offer into other
mobility offers and certain local
services offer yeah and good not
everybody knows about us and I can tell
you without having fire is that we play
in the most competitive industry in the
world and the metric for that would be
the billions that venture capital has
funneled into this into this industry
just to give you an idea we are a
unicorn but our biggest top competitors
in Latin America are 50 times bigger
than us so I don't think that happens in
many in many industries and just to give
you an idea the idea of how competitive
the landscape is is that for example of
our drivers in Brazil are not only
driving for Cavafy
but they actually working with three
phones in one of them they are qualified
and one in the other they have Dede the
Chinese giant and in the other things
are former so so is a like minute by
minute battle to get the drivers and the
riders right so I just wanted to
emphasize the real-time component of the
business because it will sustain a lot
about what we are doing all the tech we
will need in Madrid and Sapporo in
Brazil
and we're we're growing exponentially
having grown exponentially
almost for the very beginning and within
it because here we have a bunch of data
people you will understand the
difficulties on the delegates in the
number of goodness and in some extra
time tablets we have been growing
exponentially all over the their
lifespan on the of a company and the
cool thing when you get this kind of
growth is that you can start
understanding the city's what we operate
by looking at what our own data so in
this case I am just a throwing point
there is no underneath underneath a map
of drop-off locations in Madrid and as
you see the the patterns of the Main
Street start to emerge this is a part
this is whatever the this is the Retiro
part this is a highway so obviously for
safety reasons people do not report in
in the middle of the highway and in in
general you can understand how the city
works just just by looking after your
own data which is
and the other thing that is really
relevant in in riflemen and volunteer
service is that it's a non mature
industry which means that for
professional like us is is relatively
achievable to have huge impact with
relatively simple solution just to give
you a counter example if you are
optimizing the supply chain of an
advanced 380 yeah you can do that you
can do that and you can get some nice
results with Veda but probably you are
looking at a problem that thousands of
very smart people have been looking at
during the past 30 years while in
training and witness a service we are
literally look at looking at programs
that seven years ago just simply didn't
exist right because they the thing was
and the interesting wasn't here at all
so this is one example of the Vltava
files are still over there yeah so I
love to eat a dog because I start
learning that every we are all using it
for something very different that what
this one originally thought for and in
our case as I explained you we are a
very real time business and what we have
done is basically we are reporting the
cards as if they were set words right in
there you have like the blue are empty
cards the purple are with a passenger
and the yellow are going to pick up this
is how many units we are finishing per
minutes compared to before or this is
the success rate which is the number of
requests that we can actually attend
this is for a certain city and and the
cool thing is like we we have given this
to two local teams and well next time I
was in Sao Paulo three weeks ago there
was a anti-drone of computers for the
operations team and they were like added
to this team because they are actually
like triggering promotions for driver as
I told you with a competing by the
minute and and they are doing it based
on the information and they have here
also when you have these kind of things
and you have as I said before you can
understand the city from your own data
do you realize that you build something
interesting this is the graph that I saw
before this is empty cars going to pick
up and with a passenger that anyone
remembers what happened in Mexico City
in that day there was an earthquake and
I can't see in my data the precise
minute when this happened and 60% of the
mobile coverage was down in the city
that's what we are seeing so this just
by I built a seismograph ER with um
without being without internet this is
the entire point of my talk so I would
be repeating quite some quite often
another thing that you can we set a few
chintan in the in the rate of him it was
with a dynamic pricing and we decided to
break it into two completely different
part one is detecting scarcity and this
is something like a physic measurement
and this is how aggressive you wanna be
on the increasing and decreasing of the
price because we learned over time that
the price and see tivity is very
different for European users that from
that for Latin American uses basically
in Latin America the service is
affordable enough that people can
commute we terrified in as you can see I
mean maybe you can commute in in curry
with Calif I in in mobility francelina
you're lucky then but in general the
presence disease is higher there because
they are using it every day so we we
decided to break it into two and then
what we are doing without going into
much detail is just we are simply
checking how they
the recent duties were self a how long
it took for us to find a driver the cool
thing is like we are doing this at scale
so this means that every minute we are
checking up to 50,000 recent degrees and
we are making a decision about in about
hundred and thirty-five thousand regions
on the undeath on was the scarcity level
and then translating translating that
into the into the price and this is like
a feedback loop you can imagine if you
raise the price too much people would
stop the question right under there
wouldn't be a scarcity so it's there is
no forecasting this is just now casting
with a with a feedback loop circuits are
this is the kind of exercise that I that
I was saying before what we decide to to
make our decision and this is the videos
are playing for Angela
okay
so this is we're still a start-up in the
car so this is just to show you that it
took only 27 days for the algorithm to
generate an additional $1,000,000 for
our drivers considering that we launched
it the pilot project in Bogota in for
November 14th and we went from deploy
only 25 days later animation is about
and as I said this it's not like super
high impact yeah just to just to give
you an idea we made a funnel metric like
anybody in that if a driver is making
20% more because of the dynamic pricing
you can consider that he did 1.2 derbies
right so that's the value that will
produce it for him
he worked one Jimmy he got 1.2 so if you
use that magic in the first week of full
deploy we generated like over a hundred
and twenty thousand gymnast in value for
the drivers which roughly means that we
we generated the value equivalent to 2.8
million kilometers and 100,000 hours a
week as you said I mean I didn't went
into the details but probably people in
this room can understand that is not
rocket science anything nobody maybe it
is challenging to keep it at scale and
that everything works move but we we
didn't need to go too far into into
machine learning or stuff to to generate
high impact message of the talk the
other two the previous talk I think all
right hanging people especially the
design in this way we love this thing
because is when we see like we are like
making people's lives better right when
you can organize sounds of audience so
that they are all more productive or
gated or can get better service that
that's something very rewarding
and it means what we built in the world
typical taxi drivers and unless they are
driving in Manhattan that is like super
high density they are only VC thirty
percent of the time while we put
technology in the equation we can move
those numbers up to 55 even 60 percent
nowadays so yes it means we can by using
tech we can make people twice as
productive right before there was a
dream the matcha it was like the MVP of
a of the matter was very simple were
just calculating the distance with a
straight line like hover same distance
and there was some limitation on the
right right so I then ask our driver to
go to pick up for 20 kilometers right
those were they the two things the
problem with the radius is that they had
to be set like very manually by
operational teams I'm trying to gather
many things from there from the urban
density such as for the human structure
of such as density speed of the of the
streets right it's not the same if it is
highway the babies in the city centre or
like they were trying to gather money
meant many insight in the system and we
end up with with a system of over one
function manually written rules and you
can imagine that that's like impossible
to test right like how can I even Mowgli
think of testing if one additional room
rule is bringing any value in I don't
have physical power for that despite
that millions of fusion is earth that we
do and I think that has happened I think
to worry wrestling company in the
beginning is that when you have too much
when demand exceeds supply then it goes
to be good his name as the ghooost
chasing because he's like the drivers
are assigned very far and then they try
to
but people cancel and then the process
repeats and a bunch of timings is lost
so what with it and again I mean here
there is a little more complexity but
nothing crazy is that instead of
computing the word
distance we were using ETH summations
that's something I will I will talk
further now we transfer from the radius
in kilometers to an eye chakra that
because we realize that local things 90
percent of what they were trying to
mimic into the system was this idea of
like yeah I don't want the driver to
take more than five minutes to go to
pick up and if you do a nicer drone that
icicle is like updates daily I mean in
real time so if they if they traffic is
but then produces closer and many of the
things that were like manually written
it can capture data just by definition
and the other super cool thing is the is
instead of going the greedy approach
like Gimli perjuring what we start doing
is using the Hungarian algorithm for the
assignment problem which is like a
hundred year old math nothing crazy so
basically what we were doing before is
like depending on who goes first
ordering we might be doing this
assignment so this is like the driver is
going to pick up write it in here and
these in here and obviously the reason
is mark that one which is like yeah you
can just go here on this guy will go
here and when you have to it's obvious
but when you have 100 and 500 then it
gets a bit more tricky and you need to
to tackle the problem but is still
solvable in this case it has an exact
solution you don't need to do metal
restaging or crazy things do you need to
do run into that when you want to
pulling when you want to put more than
one people at the same time in the same
time but we solving get there um again
simple idea and here is rainbow it's
pretty cool how we tested the layering
scheme because what we this is like
every 13 minutes we would swap the
matching system right 1315 because we
didn't want to have seasonality effect
because some things in cities tend to
happen like a clock right and we want to
to avoid that so in general what
happened is like due to this improvement
our pickup suddenly became 30 seconds
faster on average we're talking that our
average pickup is between 4 and 5
minutes that means that our drivers are
saving to 25,000 to 35,000 hours of work
per week they are driving 500,000
kilometers less to make the same money
and provide the same value to the
passengers again simple solution super
high but it has a cut right now we are a
goldmine for commercial route providers
this ETA calculation we are requesting
commercial api's if you think about it I
suffer I will explain that later but
this doesn't scale well because
basically if the scales was the square
of the size of the business and for some
reason our CFO is not happy about it
right when your course is filled with
the square of the business with her and
so we start challenging ourselves is we
could be our own ETA estimation system
and that's what I mean telling you now
the problem is simple we need ETA for
example we do guys at this point you are
going to have to cough are not from
right do one before you hop in a car you
want to know that the right will be ten
point forty dollars and you want to keep
do you want us to keep that promise so
that means that if we were chatting by
the minute with we do at least a portion
of the price we have to make a
prediction of how long they the right
will be obviously to assign drivers and
riders this is the by far the more
intense and this is what I was referring
before that is a quadratic problem and
also another super interesting thing is
like for making our much better we need
to simulate and to simulate we sometimes
need to figure out how long would have
it take all traffic taken for a driver
to take a pass he didn't take truly bad
things about commercial providers is
that they don't give you the estimations
about the past so so in in that we hit
yes
either we figure something out ourselves
but we cannot use the simulation which
as you can imagine it helped us a lot
because yes we can go spare iment but
with experiment we cannot fine tune the
parameters of the things we need
simulation further so the objective is
super simple every five seconds each of
our drivers is telling us where he is
and what he is doing and in which
direction he is moving so we have a
bunch of data about that we don't have
any map maps are like super expensive
maybe some of our competitors can afford
like a billion dollar map division we
can load another interesting thing for
the machine learning problem is like for
a certain journey from A to B in
training time you can have the
trajectory but in evaluation time you
will do one note yet the trajectory
right
and although another very the rs.15 is
that commercial providers just give you
how long it takes driving from A to B
for matching purposes what I actually
want to know is now is like if I offered
right to a driver who is in a certain
location now moving in this speed how
long will it take for him to pick up a
passenger in here it sounds like the
same problem but it's not exactly the
same because if that driver on average
our driver then takes like 15 seconds to
set the duty in those 15 seconds maybe
it has already missed the exit or gone
in a tunnel and then that that is like a
different problem so this is just an
idea of how they will be the
experimental setup we got some a few
millions of of your knees we made like a
pnina model which was like yeah from A
to B we compute a straight these tonnes
and how long it took the model and stuff
like that as a target to surprise or of
no one the modern performs really bad
right and then it comes the magic the
magic consists of like for a journey
with not only we didn't have full
information about pick-up and drop-off
we also have the directory that
trajectory we can map it in cells this
is has anyone here heard of any kind of
geocaching so yo Hassan is typically
with squirrels these for these with use
X happens if you have ever heard of s2
which is the typical Google buck deer
Hassan this is h3 which is similar but
with excellence but basically is some
bytes that will define themselves a
region in the world in this case an
excellent
which is good like yeah in that we have
more information but what happens is
like there are like literally millions
of these cells with and if we don't want
hot encoding and we put it in a machine
learning system we are learning nothing
underneath magic we realize that the
cells in a journey behave a
statistically similar to words in
sentences in two cents one is that the
distribution is as if law in the
language do you have common words
inviting the word why and in mobility
you have transportation hubs imagine
train stations or airports and also we
realized that there is also the fan the
phenomenon the phenomenon of occurrence
which is when you see in attics Madrid
is often close to city just like cells
in a road if you were travel following
tragedies then they'd they tend to
follow roads right so given and then
there are crossings and so it was a
crazy idea that proposed by one of the
members of my team I have to honestly
say that I gave it like no credit like
yeah you can spend one week with that
but you will get nowhere and the crazy
idea was like what if we consider that
they saw a phrase and then we used a
natural language process well-known
techniques such as word to whack what we
are actually doing in a more
mathematical way is sort of an embedding
we had a something that was in melee in
the tens of millions I mentioned and we
are bringing down to only a hundred I
mentioned but what we are learning is
basically the structure of the city by
doing that and let me so itself is given
a number is given a position in a lone
dimensional space that allows you to
tell if two if two cells are close or
far away in the sense of a journey now
here's the crazy thing
this is an example cell and these are
the the cells that are closers in the
send of a journey as you can see
remember that the the system never saw a
map of the city in style in the entire
time right
it just saw trajectories so apparently
it length that this is a highway I'm
sorry if you normally read probably you
know that is like the most crowded
Highway in the city this is another
highway and apparently the system
hustling about it and when we saw these
it was like yeah it was super cool but
it didn't work right and then we went in
the map and what is happening is like
there is a tunnel from here to here GPS
in the in the tunnel doesn't work so the
deep learning has learned that this cell
is close to this cell which is pretty
cool right
is like if the vanilla model error was
here we're already hitting this this
been the whole standard being Google
real time predictions Google being a
company that has spent over a billion
dollars in building maps throwing
literally cars on the street with
cameras and tracking all Android devices
in the world and I mean we that that
would be like we're doing something
weird but we have really close enough
right and this is just an example of
like how it lands that the daily pools
of a city this is the weekend for a
certain route and this is the rush hour
in in every day how both Google and our
deep learning have learned that this
happened right we as I explained before
we also wanted the isochrones
because of the of the problem that I
mentioned before of scalability in
various patching and as you see here
they when we produce isochrones
with a deep lemon it basically captures
the pulse of the sea
so you can see down like 12 p.m. how
everything becomes closer because it is
the reservoir in UTC this is super
useful for us because commercial api's
are not providing this kind I mean some
of them claim that they provide but if
you say how much does it cost it tell
you it depends of the Mattocks of the
underlying matrix
yeah I'm still with a square with a
square cost problem just superfluous of
where we have used to do this we were
pretty happy about experimenting with
h2o by the way although go into
production with that is like freaking
expensive we don't know what we will do
about it and yeah we have used these
technologies but this is what we want to
heat the the deep learning system is not
yet in production but we know what we
want the system to perform which is like
yeah it has to be up it has to support a
hundred thousand requests in a second
the accuracy has to be less than ten
percent error on the duration of the
journey and it should be able to retrain
itself considering that we might do a
thousand units in the last minute right
why we are here as speakers and also
going around our day I really love the
previous speaker in the morning that
mention the Atlas and the heavy lifting
so I completely stole the idea is if he
around thank you anyway
right now we have four engineers and
seven data he needs and seven DBAs we
have a data scientist and because
terrifies has been mostly local
operations company until now we have a
bunch of data analyst tens of business
analysts that also run queries on our
data warehouse and this figure is quite
impressive
like everyday over 700 people logging in
our tableau system and try together to
make sense of some of some data and the
cool thing is like we you can work for
us from Brazil which is or something
that people might consider so the idea
is like we want to triple the number of
theta engineers and double the number of
data scientists for the next year
we are hiding so this is me the other is
Alberto who is sitting over there on a
red shirt he is the head of a denier and
as you can see we have plenty of
challenges we think there is a lot of
talent in in this conference or maybe
people that you know and might be
interested and the other thing is like I
don't know if you heard of not if you
didn't heard is like because you have
been hiding somewhere because he's been
all over TV for entire three days
because of political fights and we're
stuff will we are giving away free
rights for everyone today in Barcelona
Madrid Sevilla Alicante and Valencia so
so maybe our matter will find a card for
you obviously today demand exceeds
supply so you have like a 20% chance of
hope hope getting a right but still is
worth just in the service No thank you
it was a very interesting I have to
question for you
first about just well great the short
calculator and the magic system could
you tell us about about the stackins
architecture behind them and I know
globally do you have a framework to to
develop tests maybe a B test this kind
of algorithm yeah utterly building the
the ability to be able to AV test things
as complex and critical and as critical
as they as the matter is something that
it took it took me personally I was the
first data scientist at clarify a bunch
of efforts and
a lot of convincing with developers that
it was worth it
so basically now in caliphate
I could say like over 80% of the of the
platform micro-services allow us for
fine grain a beat s it means literally I
can create a cohort of users by user ID
and apply them a certain treatment
whether it is price discount these parts
in strategies or those and those are
being built as part of the feature set
of the micro service right so now when
you ask the squad that is using the
module what are the features that you
have to provide to the to the company
they will not only talk about these
patent rights but they will also mention
and we have to be able to AV test in
these two we have typically in that case
for the mature use choose permanent
settings that were designed by the data
science team and even more important
than that is that I don't think there is
a company with I mean okay a company a
start-up with five people maybe but
there is no unicorn in the world with
the risk appetite terrifies us for these
things for I am telling you the nice
part in here but while trying to improve
the matter once we broke everything
basically you when you order you may
order an executive vehicle or a regular
vehicle or even a motto a motorbike for
delivery so yes it happened to us that
we deployed with a bar and suddenly a
motorbike started to arrive to customers
that had to request it and accept the
vehicle but nothing happened we fix it
within one hour and there was like
literally no sort of retaliation for any
top management I were huh these things
happen okay thank you and the second
question about the matching system you
are using ETA two to match the driver
and the user
did you consider other valuable
information
I don't know optimus DG or something
else yeah yeah I mean I'm just
explaining here something that was my
point in this talk is like we could do
simple things with high input we have
done already more complicated things
just to give you an idea if you were
taking a write that will take one hour
and a half as a driver you don't mind to
drive for 10 minutes to pick up however
if it's a 7 minutes right you will be
super angry if you were assigned a
pickup 10 minutes right so that does
like cost per hour in dollars that the
whole the whole journey has is been
factored as an attractiveness of a theme
or also we don't because of the dynamic
pricing system we have the scarcity
detection so we favor journeys whose
destination is he is in an area where
there is a scarcity where we are lacking
cars yeah I mean as holiday I wouldn't
really to thank the previous speaker
because he basically is playing
validated my roadmap for the next two
years that's a big what we are building
and unexplained some of the problems
like if these are good as first steps
but then the matching system the
matching problem is multivariate you may
optimize different things especially it
we haven't run into that because somehow
we have ditched our drivers to affect
our journeys but for most right healing
companies in the world
the acceptance of the driver is also a
source of uncertainty so it's completely
differently if you want to optimize for
having a driver as soon as possible a
sign that if you want to optimize as we
do for productivity of the driver right
so it's a multivariate system that
depends probably on the on the market
settings and the kind of relationship
that you have with your with your agents
in the in the market place and in the
end let's be honest like probably our
tech is behind our competitors
you know they we have less than 200
engineers some of them have 5000 but we
think we can understand better the local
problems and as well as the previous
speaker worth mentioning traffic in
Indonesia we have a very big issue with
personal safety in Latin America right
and it completely flips flip the the
view in Latin America you have to
protect the driver if you just throw a
person with a bunch of cash it's like an
ATM with wheels that will come and you
can do whatever you want to him and
tackling all those local things that
change everything is where we think we
can find our competitive advantage
you